في الضفه الغربيه ا فاد مراسل الجزيره
باستشهاد سته فلسطينيين واصابه ثلاثه حاله
احدهم خطيره اثر قصف مسيره اسرائيليه لحي
المحجر المقابل لمخيم نور شمس في طول كرم
شمالي الضفه الغربيه وقال الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني ان قوات الاحتلال منعت سيارات
الاسعاف من نقل المصابين قبل ان تتمكن
احدى السيارات من نقل الشهداء وبعض
المصابين الى مستشفى ثابت ثابت الحكومي في
طول كرم وافاد شهود عيان بان شبانا مدنيين
كانوا يتابعون احداث اقتحام مخيم نور شمس
المقابر للحي عندما باغتهم مسيره واطلقت
صاروخا باتجاههم فاوقعت عددا من الشهداء
والجرحى هذا وقد اعلنت القوى الوطنيه في
محافظه طول كرم اليوم الاربعاء يوم اضراب
شامل في المحافظه حدادا على ارواح
الشهداء اظهرت مشاهد وتها منصات فلسطينيه
جانبا من الدمار الذي تسببت به قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بعد اقتحامها مناطق
متفرقه من طول كرم وكانت قوات الاحتلال قد
عمدت الى تخريب ممتلكات المواطنين واظهر
تسجيل متداول جرافه اسرائيليه وهي تقوم
بعمليات
التخريب للمتابعه تنضم الينا من طول كرم
مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البديري اره لك
الكلمه فيما يتعلق بالوضع عندك في طول كرم
في الساعات
الاخيره نحن نتواجد نشوان في حي المحجر
الذي قامت طائره مسيره باطلاق صاروخ فجر
هذا اليوم هذا جزء من التخريب والدمار
الذي حدث هنا نتيجه هذا الصاروخ ولكن
بالطبع الحدث الاهم كان هنا هو استشهاد
سته شبان هم من المدنيين لا يوجد منهم اي
مقاوم اي عسكري
وا هنا يصل تباعا الاهالي اهالي الشهداء
السته الذين يعني يحاولون فهم ما حدث في
ظل غضب شديد ايضا ه هنا كما نرى نشوان جزء
من اثار الصاروخ ايضا جزء من الرصاص الذي
اطلقه جنود الاحتلال الذين في يعني
البدايه
كان هناك شهيدان على الفور نتيجه سقوط هذا
الصاروخ اعاقت قوات الاحتلال وصول سيارات
الاسعاف مع وجود على الاقل عدد اخر
من الجرحى هنا اثار الدماء واثار الصاروخ
كما نرى هذا يعني جزء من الحفره التي حدثت
نتيجه الصاروخ الذي اطلق سيارات الاسعاف
اعيق بالكامل من الوصول الى الجرحى مما
ادى الى استشهاد شابين اخرين وتم نقل
بسياره اسعاف تمكنت من نقل
الجرحى تم اعاقتها مجددا من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الجديد والاصعب
والاخطر بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين هو ما اكده نقيب الاطباء في
طول كرم بان جندي اسرائيلي قام بالدخول
واقتحام مع عدد من الجنود سياره الاسعاف
طعن احد الجرحه بالرقبه
بسكين وتهديد باقي الجرحى بانه سيتم قتلهم
ولن يصلوا الى المستشفى ان يصل الامر الى
حد اطلاق النار ومن ثم الطعن داخل سياره
الاسعاف التي هي يفترض انها محميه وحصلت
على التنسيق
المطلوب لنقل الجرحى كان هو الاخطر كما
ذكرنا بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين سياره الدفاع المدني كما نرى
قامت خلال الساعه الماضيه
بازاله اثار الدماء ولكن نحن نستطيع ان
نشم رائحه الدماء للشهداء السته في هذه
المنطقه في المستشفى لا يزال هناك عدد من
المصابين من بينهم اصابه حرجه جدا مما قد
يرفع عدد الشهداء ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه
الاطباء يقولون ان الاصابه الحرجه هي في
داخل غرفه الانعاش
ويتم تقديم ما يلزم من علاج ايضا في داخل
مخيم ج مخيم نور شمس المقابل لحي المحجر
حيث كانت العمليه
العسكريه في الاساس عمليه عسكريه الثانيه
خلال اقل من 24 ساعه والرابعه في ثلاثه
ايام لازال هناك كما يبدو ايضا هنا كما
نرى نشوان اثار الدماء على الارض يعني كل
المحاولات فشلت نتيجه نزف الشهداء لكميه
كبيره جدا من الدماء نتيجه تعطيل عمل
سيارات الاسعاف كما ذكرنا ايضا خراب كبير
في داخل ازقه وحارات مخيم نور شمس كحي
المنشيه
وايضا حي المد فارس وتم قصف منزل وسياره
وتدمير روضه للاطفال اذا نتحدث عن عمليات
تجريف و تفجير لمواقع هي مواقع مدنيه يعني
كما ترى نشوان نحن نتحدث عن ازقه ضيقه
منطقه سكنيه ويتم اطلاق يعني صاروخ من
طائره مسيره من السماء اتجاه شبان لا
يحملون اي سلاح لا يشكلون خطر على على اي
احد وكانت كل هذه المنطقه محاصره من قبل
جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الذين بالطبع
بظل وجود كل الادوات التي يملكونها للمقار
للمراقبه واضح انهم يعلمون ان هؤلاء
الشبال ليسوا بمسلحين وكانت بالطبع ايضا
قد دارت داخل المخيم مخيم نور شمس ومن ثم
في داخل مخيم طول كرم اشتباكات مسلحه وصفت
بال العنيفه بين مقاومين فلسطينيين و ايه
جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الذين ايضا
نشروا القناصه في مواقع عده حاله من الغضب
حاله من الحزن والان اعلان الاضراب
والحداد العام على ارواح الشهداء هنا في
طول كرم وايضا على شهداء غزه وبعد صلاه
الظهر اي بعد اقل من ساعتين سيتم تشيع
الشهداء السته في موكب واحد من بين
الشهداء السته اربعه من عائله واحده شكرا
لك جيفار البدي من طول كرم مباشره مراسله
الجزيره